et on continue ce 7,8 week-end on va
parler amour et on va parler de
solidarité avec mes invités annick
renouf
bonjour vous êtes le président de
l'association ces lits loisirs henri
fall bonjour vous êtes de communication
des restos du coeur des yvelines et si
vous êtes en plateau tous les deux
ensemble et c'est qu'il y à une soirée
dansante qui est organisée samedi ce
samedi à la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux quelques jours avant la saint
valentin et que les fonds récoltés vont
être offerts aux restos du coeur des
yvelines alors c'est un peu étonnant
cette rencontre entre une association de
célibataire est une association de
solidarité comme les restos du coeur et
micro nous fait expliquez-nous votre
rencontre à tous les deux pas vraiment
étonnant si voulez moi je suis donateurs
un titre privé j'écoute la télé la radio
comme tout le monde il ya quelques temps
un certain temps maintenant on a parlé
de des réductions qui elle est très haut
niveau de l'europe est sous les jets
considérant que notre association est
une association de dîners de célibataire
avant que ce soit de l'association de
soirée assez réputés en matière de
qualité de dîner j'ai trouvé naturel
qu'on vienne en aide ceux qui sont
beaucoup plus défavorisés que nous
prenons et c'est ici on a été surpris
parce que d'habitude doyer c'est des
associations caritatives du type lion's
club rotary accès à qui viennent vers
nous et là une association de céder à
terre et de loisirs
mais nous on cherche des sous donc dans
la mesure où on nous apporte des
souhaité que l'association a très bonne
réputation on était partant justement
vous dites d'habitude c'est plutôt dans
ce club où le retard et qui
interviennent est ce que justement il ya
des associations comme ça n'ont pas
forcément de solidarité la base qu'il y
en a près il y en a beaucoup y
on a souvent ce sont des concerts ou des
manifestations sportives
moi je vous cite le landbote le hand
ball club de beynes qui fait tout une
manifestation la fin février et au
profit des restos du coeur vous avez les
la chorale de et les instruments de
musique de conflent qui font aussi
quelque chose donc on a beau pas mal
d'associations qui font des
manifestations et qui sont l'occasion de
donner de l'argent un peu à nos restos
du coeur qui en ont besoin jusqu'à oui
justement parce que madame nous vous en
parler et puis c'est en en paix laquelle
luttent en semant puisque nous sommes
nous sommes vendredi et c'est le dernier
jour pour le parlement à bruxelles pour
étudier justement ce plan daide
européens aux associations caritatives
ya pas que le resto du coeur qui sont
concernés mais il ya aussi des restos du
coeur
est ce que vous sentez justement
puisqu'on en parle beaucoup dans les
médias vous avez raison un moine ou
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que de
plus en plus d'associations viennent
vous voir vous contacter ou même des
particuliers qui disent on va venir vous
aider parce que financièrement
vous allez pouvoir y arriver s'il ya
plus de l'aide européenne je pense que
le problème de l'aide européenne et je
croise les doigts aujourd'hui pour
respirer que une décision positive mais
ce problème qui est depuis déjà plus
d'un an sur la table fait que je pense
il ya pas mal de gens qui viennent nous
voir en nous disant on peut vous aider
et je crois qu'on a besoin de tout de
l'aide européenne mais aussi de l'aide
de voir monsieur réal voir des portes
coire et locales je reviens sur cette
soirée alors qu'est ce qui va se passer
cette soirée du samedi 9 armes du manet
hamon qui s'adresse cette soirée bien
des célibataires des gens de divorcer à
des gens seuls qui vont venir pour un
apéritif qui va commencer à 20h a duré
jusqu'à 21h ensuite ils passent à table
sur un dîner
très sympathique cambrai jusque là
rennes positifs passent à table et c'est
vous qui allez faire le tour de table
sait on qui allait faire le placement
non pas du tout vengeance
les gens profitent de l'apéritif pour
faire connaissance c'est un apéritif qui
est servi en buffet pour qu'ils puissent
discuter autour d'un apéritif et des
petits fours qui vont avec et ensuite en
fonction des connaissances qu'ils ont
fait à cet apéritif
ils vont décider de même des coûts vives
qui sont de leur côté en fait c'est une
fois qui évidemment est payante
cinquante deux 52 euros et sur ces cinq
dîners et soirées dans son dîner et
soirée dansante et sur ces 52 euros
précisément combien du coup vont être
reversés le règlement c'est pas très
bien parce qu'il ya vraiment un sens oui
il yal'affaire szymanek qu'il faut louer
le dj qu'il faut payer
là on sait que ça sort en positif déjà
nous avons 160 réservations pour demain
et en deuxième partie de soirée à 23
heures il ya des gens qui vont venir
danser on peut en avoir 30 50 80 on ne
sait pas encore beaucoup de monde au
vous êtes au niveau dîner en ait foule
l'atakor fidélisation les manger sur
désistement
par contre pour danser c'est open à
partir de 23 heures demain et jusqu'à
3h30 d'accord un petit mot sur votre
association céline loisirs c'est la
seconde donc vous l'avez de célibataire
voilà autre cette soirée que vous
organisez la ferme du manège qui tombe
évidemment très bien à quelques jours de
la saint-valentin on souhaite que des
couples se forment justement avant le 14
février
qu'est ce que vous proposez d'autres eh
bien on est on est spécialisé dans ce
domaine essentiellement des dîners
suivi de suren ensemble donc des lieux
plutôt choisi du 78 prochainement le 2
mars on met un saint germain en laye et
le 13 avril ont fait les 13 ans de
l'association au château d'if est
amoureux court 13 ans le 13 avril
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée de
créer cette association je suis moi même
divorcé en d'autres temps j'ai fréquenté
des clubs de loisirs pour célibataires
et j'ai eu les mêmes à trouver votre
bonheur dans ces clubs de loisirs vous
êtes volant sont si si c'est pas ça me
donne de trouver l'âme soeur faut avoir
l'honnêteté de le dire aux gens mais
c'était pour moi mon sport j'adorais
danser en fait mais vous avez eu l'idée
de créer cette association parce que je
me suis retrouvé comme d'autres femmes
cadres qui n'est plus tout à fait 25 ans
au chômage je n'ai pas retrouvé de job
et quitte à nous de bosser pour rien
j'ai choisi de me faire plaisir en
créant cette association mais maintenant
je suis à la retraite depuis quelques
années vous fait plaisir mais vous fait
aussi plaisir à vos adhérents et
adhérentes les vraies histoires qui se
crèvent à voter dès fois décomptés ah
oui moi y avait plus que ces couples
mariés et coup une relation fidéliser
parce que on ne se remarie pas forcément
à ce jour couple connu 82 82 et plus
potentiellement parce qu'on ne sait pas
tout dans ce domaine est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que les gens qui
viennent vous voir et sondé parce
qu'aujourd'hui on oublie pour rencontrer
l'amour il ya aussi internet c'est réel
développé la même chose c'est pas la
même c'est pas que ça n'a rien à voir
avec les sites de rencontre c'est
beaucoup plus convivial on vient d'abord
pour s'y faire des amis l'élargir son
cercle amical
parce qu'il faut peut-être pas arrivé
avec la pression en disant surtout
passer ce soir ou jamais que je
rencontre la femme ou l'homme de base
meilleure façon de ne pas de l'oeil
parce que là si on se met la pression
c'est fini ça marche pas c'est comme la
spontanéité qui donc il reste d'être
homo en matière d'amour non et puis on
s'aperçoit si vous voulez qu on est très
informatisée 1 grâce à notre trésorier
qui est aussi le master bénévoles de
l'association
il ya tout il ya toujours un
renouvellement permanent a
malheureusement des divorces
il y en a de plus en plus je crois et on
s'aperçoit que quand un couple s'est
formé quand on le sait avec certitude
que c'est quelqu'un que ce soit un homme
ou une femme qui vient depuis un certain
temps qui va rencontrer une personne
nouvelle qui est venu à une ou deux
soirées pas plus parce que l'internât
juste on a justement
quarante-et-une personnes nouvelles ce
qui est rare comme un chiffre de nos
soir d'accord en principe c'est la
trentaine l'appel est lancé pour ceux
qui veulent avoir une carte id à la
quarantaine de nouvelles personnes est
ce qu'il ya un critère d'âge de notre
association il ya un critère d'âge parce
que la difficulté c'est d'équilibrer les
dîners en femme il y en avait pas aux
débuts de l'association
donc je gérais des listes d'attentes
sans fin de femmes de 50 ans et plus et
en 2004 j'ai soumis ce problème de
listes d'attentes à nos adhérents lors
d'une assemblée générale
et il a été voté que la limite de
premier accueil pas de renouvellement
mais de premier accueil était à 55 ans
et on respecte cette limite d'accord
donc au dessus au dessus de quelqu'un
qui a adhéré à 54 kilomètres à près de
56 pour être vrai mais sinon je renvoie
dans d'autres entités après 55 ans pour
des gens qui pour ne connaît pas qui ne
sont jamais vous d'accord et puis je
suis d'un arc et sur les goûts les prêts
je veux revenir avec vous aurez fall sap
est facile la transition pour parler
d'amour à des restos du coeur mais bon
on va parler du reste
une dernière question qui m'a et je
voulais un petit conseil est ce que vous
auriez un conseil à donner à nos
célibataires qui nous écoutent
c'est quoi le secret pour rencontrer au
moins pour pour 4
être soi même sortir osé sortir de chez
soi je crois que c'est le pas le plus
difficile à faire parce que quand on
arrive dans ce genre de soirée d'abord
il faut bien se dire que tous les gens
sont même cas de figure qu'on est
vraiment pas tout seul ça relativise le
drame
et je pense que si on est plus détendu
plus ouvert aux autres
ça facilite la communication ça donne
des relations amicales et plus si
affinités comme on dit donc il faut
s'ouvrir aux autres
à l'angle a été en effet la transition
est toute trouvée le moqueur le moqueur
de perez et restos du coeur quand même
un petit mot donc sur ce plan d'eau
européen dead qui est en ce moment
étudiée à bruxelles au niveau des restos
du coeur des yvelines vous avez constaté
une augmentation importante du nombre de
familles aidées
ah oui c'est sûr cette année on a une
assez forte augmentation l'année
dernière à la même époque on est et à
9900 famille maintenant on est à 10700
aider c'est à dire c'est + 8 % d'une
d'une année sur l'autre l'année dernière
on était on avait terminé à 12 milles
j'ai dit famille ces personnes on était
indéterminée à 12000 personnes et on
pense que cette année on terminera 13000
personnes aidées sur les 18 que des
discussions au parlement de bruxelles il
s'avère que l'union européenne ne pourra
plus ne souhaitera plus aidé alors ça
sera peut-être pas aussi brutalement ça
sera pas beau de l'année prochaine et
nous avons envisagé des solutions
d'autres somme non il n'ya pas il n'y a
pas de solution enfin il faut discuter
maintenant peut-être localement ou avec
les l'état français mais nous on n'a pas
de solution en tire c'est oui et c'est
25% de ce qu'on donne c'est à dire on
donne mille tonnes de notre de
nourriture 25% ses 250 tonnes ça fait
vingt-cinq camion de 10 tonnes
je sais pas les trouver alors même avec
beaucoup d'associations comme si les
loisirs que je remercie mes jean
n'arrivera pas donc il faudra il faut il
photo il n'y a pas de solution
aujourd'hui quoi la solution ça passe
soit par des mécènes sont restés muets
soit les oies l'état soit l'état
français qui substitue à l'europe soient
la région soit le département soit les
communes soit je ne sais je sais pas
quoi c mais on n'a pas de solliciter
faire mois 25% en produits de nouri en
nourriture on sait pas le comble est
juste en allant chercher un peu plus de
nourriture à la ramasse 2
dans les grandes surfaces quoi c'est pas
c'est pas possible
écoutez à suivre à suivre il viendrait
certainement son plateau de téléfoot
pour pour les bonnes nouvelles
merci à vous d'être revenu sur un
plateau télé filez donc je rappelle
cette cette soirée dont il ya plus de
place pour le dîner mais on peut encore
venir danser seelandais célibataire
samedi 9 février à la ferme du manet à
montigny le bretonneux s'est organisée
par l'association céline loisirs et
c'est au profit des restos du coeur
merci beaucoup à vous d'être revenu sur
ce plateau